welcome back so last time we discussed
how the transfer function G is
essentially the Laplace transform of our
state space system and it's a complex
valued function so this G lives in the
so the variable axis is G of s and s
lives in the complex plane okay and
essentially if I plug in I Omega into G
of s so G of I Omega tells me what the
system does if I give it a pure tone
forcing in an IR Omega frequency so sine
Omega T in gives me a sine Omega T plus
C out this is just a true fact for all
linear systems
if I plug an input sine wave into my
system I get an output sine wave of the
same frequency but it might have a
different magnitude and phase and so the
transfer function if I evaluate G at I
Omega so this is like a sine wave in the
complex plane the magnitude of G I Omega
is the amplitude of my output sine wave
and angle of G I Omega is the phase of
my output sine wave and so what I want
to do is illustrate what this means
physically for something like the spring
mass damper system okay so I'm going to
draw the trusty old spring mass damper
okay I've got a spring I've got a damper
and attached to that is some mass M okay
we're going to say you know this is some
spring constant K some damper D and the
position of the system X is essentially
how far this mass is from rest okay so
this is relatively easy to derive the
equations of motion I'm just kind of
Newton's law for the spring mass system
you get something like X double dot
let's say MX double dot okay this is my
force or my sorry mass times
acceleration equals force and so there
- K X and a minus BX dot so if I bring
them over to the left side I get a plus
the X dot plus K X equals whatever
external forcing I put on the system so
any leftover forces like if I am moving
the base or if I have you know something
that I hit this with a hammer those all
go into my forcing you okay it's a
really simple Newton's law here and we
know that if I wanted to I could build
an Augmented system I could build a
state-space system by introducing X and
X dot at states of the system so what
we're going to do now is essentially
look at the Laplace transform of this
this system and then we're going to
build something called the frequency
response or the bode plot okay and so
just recall that if I take the Laplace
transform of the derivative of D DX
sorry D DT of X if I take the Laplace
transform of X dot I just get F times
the Laplace transform of X minus X
naught okay and so what we're going to
do usually in transfer function land in
Laplace transform world what we're going
to do is we're going to assume that all
of the initial conditions and transients
died out and so we're only going to
consider this term here we're going to
assume that X naught and X dot naught
are all 0 so no initial conditions but
you don't have to do that you could use
these to solve for the initial condition
response so we're going to use this for
X 0 equal 0 and then what we also have
is we run this through again we get the
Laplace transform of the squared DT x
equals s squared times the Laplace
transform of my variable X and this is
really nice because I'm taking
differential equations derivatives and
I'm turning them into just algebraic
terms products of s Squared's and stuff
let's say I plugged some real numbers in
here I just have a certain mass and a
certain damping constant and certain
spring so I'm just going to plug in
numbers here I'm going to say let's say
my system is X double dot let's say plus
X dot plus X I'm going to keep it real
simple all my constants are 1 and that
equals you okay now we know how to solve
this oh de in general right I could plug
in e to the lambda T and I would get
lambda squared plus lambda plus 1 e to
the lambda T and I would get my
characteristic polynomial if I plug in
these terms if I take the Laplace
transform of both sides and I plug in
these formulas I get something very
similar to my characteristic polynomial
so what I get is f squared X bar plus F
X bar plus X bar equals u bar
now remember bar just means I'm in the
Laplace transform domain I've Laplace
transform that function of time into a
function of s my Laplace variable and
now I can factor out on both sides my s
squared plus s plus 1 times X bar equals
u bar ok so this is pretty pretty simple
this is my characteristic polynomial so
the roots of this function are the
eigenvalues of my system they're the
e to the lambda T's that that solved the
system and so finally I can say X bar
over u bar equals 1 over s squared plus
s plus 1 and this is my transfer
function G of s this is how you get it
super simple okay you Laplace transform
your OD e and you essentially rearrange
and collect like variables so you get
your X bars and your u bars on one side
and then you can write this transfer
function from you in this case I'm
measuring X so y equals x and so my
transfer function from u to X is this
one over my characteristic polynomial
and that's generally the case of these
simple linear systems okay now we're
going to use this to actually figure out
this a and this fee function here okay
so I could literally take this complex
function and I could plug in I Omega for
all omegas for all frequencies and I
could compute the magnitude and the
phase and that would tell me what the
output signs look like given an input
sign but I like to actually do this with
an experiment okay so here I have my
trusty
who may be black was the wrong color for
this room so I have my trusty spring
mass damper system okay you can kind of
see it and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to force the system at different
frequencies and in fact I'm going to
make what's called a frequency response
okay so I'm going to build this
frequency response let's do it right
here okay I'm going to plot a and C
remember a is just magnitude of G I
Omega and this is phase of G I Omega and
I'm going to plot this as a function of
Omega as a function of how fast I'm
whipping this thing up and down how fast
I'm forcing this u equals sine Omega T
okay and a couple of important things
you mega is going to be on a log scale
so these are really low frequencies over
here really high frequencies over here a
is also going to be on a log scale so
negative means really really small
amplitude positive means really really
big amplitude okay and so let's let's
start doing so this is an example I
always do in my class I really hope you
can see this phone okay so if I move my
hand if I move my forcing Omega really
slow so I have a slow sine wave what is
the phone amplitude do what is the
measurement of this phone's position
well it's a sine wave that exact
we tracks the input sine-wave okay so
the amplitude is 1 and the phase is 0
okay so let's write that down
so for really low frequencies I have an
amplitude essentially of 1 and I have a
phase that's 0 and if I if I make this
thing arbitrarily slow it'll have the
same behavior the output will track
exactly input if I put in an input sine
wave the output sine will be exactly the
same with a equals 1 and C equals 0 okay
this is zero degrees and that's
amplitude 1 so now let's say that I take
this thing and I go to ultra ultra high
frequencies okay this is a little harder
to do but I'll try and it might be
harder to see so now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to whip the my hand up
and down really really fast so I'm
moving my hand really really really
really fast
and you can see I mean this thing has an
oscillating mode out of plane but it's
not moving up and down if I move my hand
really really really really fast this
thing basically stays put and the faster
I move my hand the lower the amplitude
goes so this a gets smaller and smaller
and smaller
the faster Omega is so asymptotically
this kind of this this will go down to
zero amplitude and it's hard to figure
out exactly what the phase is just from
watching it but if I plugged in really
high frequency Omega into here I would
find out that I picked up a minus 180
degrees out of phase so it turns out
that I'll be minus 180 degrees out of
phase asymptotically now in the middle
this is where it's really interesting
okay so for example in the middle
there's some sweet spot frequency let's
see if I can do this where there's some
sweet spot where if I move my hand a
little I can get this thing really
jumping can you see that like yeah the
phone is I'm moving my hand just barely
but I'm making the phone jump a lot
maybe I'll bring my marker here so do it
again okay so I'm moving my hand
little us is almost impossible two hands
but the amplitude is going huge okay
when there is some sweet spot frequency
the resonant frequency there's some
resonant frequency where this amplitude
actually goes up so where a is actually
bigger than one I put in a little sine
Omega T I get a big sine Omega T out and
at that point I pass through minus
ninety degrees of phase so if you
noticed when I do that it's a little
hard to make it exaggerated but as my
hand is moving up and down and I'm
making this thing jump the phone is
going in the opposite direction of my
hand okay so they're approaching and
then a divergent approaching diverging
so the phone is minus 90 degrees out of
phase with my hand okay so this is
called this is a super useful plot this
is called the bode plot after a guy
named bode or it's also called the
frequency response and this very very
simple picture essentially tells me
everything about what my system does at
all frequencies so if I have something
complicated like the Hubble Space
Telescope or the International Space
Station I might want to look at the bode
plot to see how does this thing going to
oscillate where are its resonant peaks
what do I have to actively control to
make this thing not shake itself into
pieces okay and this is one of the
reasons the transfer function is so
useful is because if I have a transfer
function I can literally plug in I Omega
and sweep through Omega and the
magnitude and phase of this function can
give me all of this information so very
very useful the last thing I'm going to
show you is actually this is really
simple to do in that lab okay so let's
do this in MATLAB let's say first things
first what I'm going to do is I'm going
to define s equals TF of s so this is
how you start in MATLAB if you want to
do transfer functions you say I'm going
to define a Laplace variable and it's a
transfer function of the Laplace
variable otherwise s could be anything s
could be an
number or a script or something like
that so let me get rid of this okay so
the first thing I have to do is define
my Laplace variable then I'm going to
build my system my G I'm going to say G
equals 1 over and I think I had s
squared plus s plus 1 ok
that's my transfer function that's all
it is I hit enter okay I have a
continuous time transfer function called
G so now this is where it gets really
cool in MATLAB I can compute the bode
plot really really easily it's one line
I say bori of G and what it's going to
do is essentially it sweeps through all
of Omega this is frequency Omega and
radians per second so it's going to
sweep through all of these frequencies
and it's going to evaluate G I Omega and
compute its magnitude and its phase and
you can see here's the magnitude in log
plot in decibels and just like what we
predicted for very low frequencies the
output has 0 DB so the log of 1 is 0 so
the amplitude is 1 meaning that the sine
wave is exactly the same as the input
sine wave and the phase is 0
as I increase the forcing frequency and
you can probably see this now against
our behind the white background as I
increase the forcing frequency I hit
this resonant peak here where the
telephone is jumping and then for really
really really high frequencies my
amplitude decays so if I move my hand a
lot the phone doesn't move hardly at all
okay and so this is really easy one line
in MATLAB just bowi of G and you sweep
through this whole frequency response
curve for this system now if I had a
system that had a lot more damping so if
this term it's my X dot term is a lot
higher then maybe this thing wouldn't
oscillate so much maybe it would die out
quickly and not have a resonant peak or
if I made this damping much much smaller
maybe I could make my resident peak much
much bigger okay so if I make my damping
smaller ten times smaller now I've got
this let me move it over here now I've
got this monster resident peak here
because I have such small damping if I
force this thing a little it's really
going to whip wildly around okay so I
got this big resonant peak all I did was
decrease damping okay so this also fits
our intuition it makes sense and if I
increase the damping a lot so let's say
I make this ten times bigger than my
original damping I should completely get
rid of my my resonant peak and in fact
something weird happen because I made it
I made it too big and I could probably
go for that's that's probably a good one
okay other cool things you can do once
you have a transfer function in MATLAB I
can compute the impulse response I can
compute the step response so let's do
that
so let's redefine my G to be the
original G and let's just type in
impulse of G so now what you see is if I
this is if I had my system and I whacked
it with a hammer the position will
increase then overshoot and oscillate
and eventually go back to rest but it's
going to do it by oscillating back to
rest and that's what this impulse
response tells me okay so that's
literally if I took this system and I
whack it with a hammer okay now if I do
a step response let's do that if I have
a step response see now it goes from
zero to one and it oscillates while it
does it so that's if I take this system
and instead of just whacking it once I
give it like a constant offset function
so I force it forever at some value but
I step my control from zero to one
that's kind of like if I jump this thing
down so notice I just drop my control it
oscillates and it ends up at a different
study state value so now its position is
one where it used to be zero okay so
lots you can do with Laplace transform
try
for functions they tell you how the
input sine waves turn into output sine
waves they give you the amplitude and
the phase just by evaluating G at i/o
Mecca really easy to code up in that lab
easy to compute from an OD e and then
what we're going to find is that looking
at properties of let me bring up the
bode plot by looking at properties of
this frequency response plot we'll be
able to tell is our system robust is it
not robust where is it sensitive what
kind of disturbances can it reject what
kind of noise is it sensitive to we're
going to be able to get all of that
intuitively from these these frequency
response plots and it's all coming up
thank you